[Applause]
you chose the wrong side
you
hey youtubers is Charlie new Captain
America Civil War Superbowl trailer you
chose the wrong side so let's break it
down first things first I don't know if
this is gonna be the last trailer they
post tonight they might post a longer
version of this if they do I'll totally
do video for it but I think this is it I
think this is the only thing they're
gonna post tonight as you can tell
they're just piggybacking on the
Superbowl hyping up the big rivalry
between team cap and team Iron Man we
get a full look at the teams nice look
at Black Panther we see the vision
finally we see ant-man
with a new helmet the weird chant that
they have going on is also a little bit
reversed if it sounds weird to you
normally it'd be united we stand divided
we fall
but the chant is saying we stand united
and then as it shows team Iron Man it
says we fall long dramatic pause divided
so obviously everybody's gonna fall at
the end of the movie just like war
machine here is Iron Man pulls his mask
off I don't think that he winds up dead
but somebody is gonna die at the end of
this movie
just remember Doctor Strange might have
the time gem so that might be a way to
bring people back we also have the
Infinity Gauntlet infinity war there's
gonna be like 66 characters it's gonna
be so freakin amazing
it's gonna be like all the Marvel movies
got together had an orgy and that baby
is infinity War part 1 & 2 so other
really awesome stuff in this trailer
Iron Man with a quick save for the win
just BAM pulls the glove out stops the
bullet cap here looks like he's getting
ready to throw up in his mouth when he
finds Bucky this might be a Hydra
facility remember they're still Hydra
cells all over the earth they've been
trying to dismantle so this is him
probably just finding his location like
oh my god look what they've done to my
friend I can't let him go to jail
this is Winter Soldier in full battle
gear I know it seems like he's wearing
civilian clothes for a big part of the
movie that might come early on it looks
like he throws on the rest of his armor
when he and cap go on the run although
these two scenes might be from two
completely different parts of the movie
they cut trailers and very misleading
ways I just love these lineups though
you chose the wrong side so let me know
what you guys think and let me know what
you think of the new ant-man costume
obviously it's just an upgrade he just
got some Avengers technology as part of
the Avengers and who knows how long
that's gonna last or whether he actually
becomes a formal member of the Avengers
before all goes crazy it sounds
like they call him in for help late in
the game
like he doesn't officially start out in
the Avengers facility he's off on
zone but if you guys haven't seen it I
just did a big Captain America versus
guardians of the galaxy 2 video I
explained the new modified phase 3 they
changed a bunch of films ant-man and the
wasp is gonna be the ant-man sequel that
wasn't on the books before that there's
gonna be 11 films total in phase 3 this
is the first Captain America Civil War
is the first phase 3 film so be sure to
subscribe to get everything else tonight
there's gonna be a couple more trailers
they'll be x-men apocalypse maybe some
more Deadpool stuff I've seen a little
bit of Batman V Superman stuff but it's
not an official trailer so I'm just
gonna wait and see what they post
whatever ends up happening it's gonna be
awesome there's gonna be a whole bunch
of stuff tonight if you guys haven't
seen it I've just posted a Deadpool vs.
Wolverine Deadpool on cable sequel video
you can click here to learn all about
that and you can click here for all my
other Captain America Civil War videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you